we love you shooting like you're good in
court he's my burgers good and [ __ ] hey
you get corn buddy and it gets all
fattening my god
[Music]
welcome to wagons egg with Kevin Andy
the only show to takes you into the loop
Creek kitchen makes you handy or give
you an e I'm not quite sure which Thank
You Man
it's kind of a great shift its
pleasurable again okay what we're going
to do today to smoke some hash fools
that's right finally on a show called
wake and bake we're gonna smoke some
acid but anything ever went no Kevin
it's not it's not hashish
it is corned beef hash a traditional
breakfast food this will not disappoint
no because not only is it going to be
corned beef hash but this being repaid
kitchen our special ingredients today is
will be cool ranch Dorito dust and spicy
sriracha and ranch dressing all right
sir what are we going to need to make
today's dish well the ingredients are
russet potatoes sweet potatoes oats corn
beef chopped onion red bell pepper
butter two eggs chopped flat-leaf
parsley crushed Cool Ranch Doritos spicy
sriracha ranch sauce first up we need to
put a little oil in here do about three
tablespoons to spoon you going to eat
you like it a little I do
I know me I like oil out here you're
like so going dry let's talk about sex
baby I start about you and me birth to
the cart what next well now we want to
put our butter in this is our second oil
and we'll let that foam up so we're
using butter on top of oil butter and
oil go together like Kevin and Andy all
right what do we do we're going to put
the onions in is important to get every
last one cuz this will make people come
out
let's he's wanted Lindh you can make a
whole Pixar movie about this guy
and now this is some peppers that's some
red pepper okay and we're going to let
it up away I'm going to stir it up
little darling and get this thing get
its brown a little bit so this is the
basis for our hash there you can let it
rest there so you can brown a little bit
okay good good you left it we'd love to
you know caramelize some onions in a pan
to start a lot of stuff so hash super
good
all right what do we put in that well as
after this browser a little bit we'll
put in the corn three note the corn a
corn beef and they feed corn to the
animal while it's alive
that's they put them on a special corn
diet well we love you soon like you're
digging for these muggers good and [ __ ]
hey you get corn buddy and it gets all
fat my god it's a theory but no it
refers to large salt crystals for curing
the meat they call those salt corn it
has nothing to do with I'm eatin corn
take a corn
I didn't like a report in school when I
was like 12 and I got an egg they were
just like ah if I give them a see I have
to talk to him
start the brown and it's browning
browning method yeah get down into Brown
Kevin handy like that mmm
here is your corned beef it's also
Stephen country has that a lot of
seasoning okay
stick that in there now we get our
starches in there my friend
it smells so good I forgot fuel my
asking
well that is the cure cure Idaho rocket
like kale and here we have our carrots
sweet potato that's a sweet Patel you
that we really want to focus this up
with sweet potato so what we're going to
do here is we're going to make little
well sorta like we're making
toad-in-the-hole going to set a toast
it's going to be the hash and we can
call it going old ooh let's call it but
keep it seen like Indiana Jones we're
going to make it Louis so today I got a
couple holes here Andy I need you to
fill them I know that sounds dirtier
than I meant it but you find a hole
filling whoa he's a one-hitter grandpa's
a one-hitter alright so now we put a lid
on this [ __ ] while that goes I'm going
to fill up our pepper grinder our pepper
mill if you will our pepper potts with
some very cool things that we thought
you made it relevant to me and I this is
a I can do whatever I want because for
the next three minutes and like an
American I can do whatever I want
goddamn and we order this agree yes
we're the king is another loot crate
kitchen beds right thanks familiar with
diner jargon we talked about this on the
podcast one diner jargon yeah should
they say at a diner thing to how they
make orders so if you say I would like
scrambled eggs on toast they would turn
to the kitchen say give me an Adam and
Eve on a raft and recommed oh they got
name yeah yeah all the speaking in code
my god it's like they Apache wing
talkers I heard the waitress who waited
on me at last restaurant as she walked
away she went to the kitchen this fat
[ __ ] off food well you know what they
call hash
what it called sweep the kitchen
sweeping margins everyone goes red in
there yeah I said a hash mark it's
called a hash mark because it's from
chopping up hash over they called the
back alley as well it is called the back
alley everyone has to like give him a
back out back alley mystery beggarly
mystery yeah sounds like a it sounds
like a rectal tissue doesn't sound like
a porno back history we're taking our
cover off very important to do that oh
[ __ ] varying cover not to talk to
there's a hot metal verb there we can
play time I know but I feel like I could
do it I'm 46 I should be able to
manipulate food without
look at my ant-man plate he looks like
he's like don't put that hot hash on me
photos videos are not food look look I
know Spidey please all right
preciate spider plank here we go get on
to it
watch your printer's hot nicely done
thank you like that that's a back alley
mystery six of those weights agree so
why don't you garnish with a little
parsley that goes on isn't I go on top
no kind of cigar Instagram right so this
we just waddle upon and on there I'm not
the reason I did the parsley first look
it out look at me that just drips on
could be worse oh boy this is like a
Hidden Valley commercial it really is
look at mystery alley and Hidden Valley
now can we do those burritos there we go
what do we do add your ingredients maze
grind it on there no yeah no why is
nobody ever done this before this is so
smart we should put this on everything I
think so too I think that why are we
using salt and pepper when we could be
using Dorito shapes here we go man raise
smoke this hash right into our mouths
how did you know what am i lying for the
cameras that is [ __ ] close this is
really special man only place you'll
find this being cooked on the internet
right here in the loop cake kitchen with
Craig calm you enjoyed watching me and
Andy cook do you enjoy watching this eat
cuz we're gonna do a new show called
twinken bear eating food basically just
where we're going to eat shirtless make
suggestions like that right to the Sun
so everything Destin's like please do
exalt a maternal write to his Twitter
Instagram Facebook hashtag it lootcrate
and let us know what you would like to
see us cook man because Andy knows how
to cook everything this was a phenomenal
meal and for wake-and-bake with Kevin
Andy I'm Kevin and I'm Annie Bon Appetit
[Music]
you